I would love for anyone who watches the
film to take away first of all a feeling
of where the music came from you know
there's a lot of African roots in not
only Latin music but particularly Cuban
music I think that you see the longevity
of this genre the fact that it is still
very much alive and on this record even
though we did a little more fusion than
we did on madera it is very much root
oriented and it people still enjoy it
and it still sounds fresh it's not
getting recorded a lot but for us it was
a responsibility to preserve as they
have all these amazing maestro's and
legends that are on this record as they
have spent their lives doing to keep the
music alive in its pure form and also as
in my pop career in that fusion that was
who we are you know from our our
homeland and mixed in with this homeland
because I feel very much the United
States to me is also my homeland and so
I hope that people realize that music is
something that really does transcend
many many different things